herrn und frauen die einst kinder war er
steht auf diesem platz der arm hat schon
gekannt
was ihr hier seht christkindlesmarkt
genannt und wer da kommt
der soll willkommen sein
auf diesen moment haben tausende in
nürnberg gewartet der christkindlesmarkt
ist offiziell eröffnet
die besucher kommen wegen
weihnachtsschmuck nürnberger lebkuchen
rostbratwürsten und einer tasse glühwein
aber erst der auftritt ist christkind
macht den markt perfekt wider was
besonderes wenn der prolog gehalten wird
wir sind extra deswegen gekommen
es ist schön einfach unglaublich wenige
stunden zuvor letzte vorbereitungen für
das christkind ganz ohne kostüm und
perücke die 19 jährige barbara otto
spielt die rolle schon zum zweiten mal
doch von routine kann keine rede sein
ganz unbeschreiblich man steht dann da
oben die menschen unten warten auf einen
irgendwann geht das licht an und man
freut sich einfach total dass es jetzt
wirklich losgeht
für die tonprobe geht es auf den balkon
der frauenkirche
alle zwei jahre wählt eine jury aus
vielen bewerberinnen eine junge
nürnbergerin als christkind aus zu den
aufgaben gehören nicht nur der auftritt
heute sondern mehr als 150 termine in
der vorweihnachtszeit
die herausforderung für barbara otto
trotz zeitdruck immer himmlische ruhe
bewahren
das christkind gehört seit jahrhunderten
zum deutschen weihnachtsfest es bringt
den kindern ein heiligabend die
geschenke in manchen regionen
deutschlands wurde es inzwischen
allerdings vom aus den usa importierten
weihnachtsmann verdrängt
der weihnachtsmarkt dagegen wurde aus
deutschland in die ganze welt exportiert
keiner ist so berühmt wie der in
nürnberg mit immer demselben
erfolgsrezept regionale spezialitäten
und handwerkskunst
das christkind wurde als wahrzeichen des
marktes in den 1930 er jahren eingeführt
ballkleid und perücke machen kostüm
direktorin eva weber und ihre
kolleginnen am nürnberger staatstheater
keine experimente materialien variieren
ab und so ein bisschen aber das modell
als solches und die steinchen drauf und
so nehmen wir eigentlich von dem
vorherigen modell und wir denken ist es
einfach ein markenzeichen und auch wenn
die mädchen sich verändern das kleid
also ich es soll immer wieder wieder
erkennbar sein
zurück bei barbara otto sie ist in kleid
und rolle geschlüpft
vor der kirche wird es christkind schon
erwartet
ja
und während die kleinen ihre wünsche
loswerden können die großen auf dem
christkindlesmarkt schon mal einkaufen
was an eigentlich abend unter dem
weihnachtsbaum liegen soll